all right listen I don't believe that at
this time Ron DeSantis has a path to the
Republican nomination until something
changes unless something changes but
the numbers can't be denied this is not
a show where I would ever try to deny
the numbers thank your lucky stars every
day you're not Dave Pacman well listen
but I'm not going to deny the numbers
Alex please
since news of Ron desantis's
presidential announcement broke
desantis's polling is up 15 percent
while Donald Trump's polling is down
five percent now I hate that I have to
do this but I need to just do my
disclaimer about the difference between
percent and percentage points if you go
from 10 to 15 you start at 10 you go to
15 that's an increase of Five Points
but it is an increase of 50 percent okay
you've gained five and you started at
10. that is a 50 increase but a five
point increase understanding this
mathematical nuance and looking at
average polling we see that Donald Trump
peaked at 56.3 and is now down since the
santhis announcement to 53.2 that's a
decline of close to six percent we'll
call it five percent
similarly DeSantis bottomed at 19.4 just
before his announcement and has now
climbed to 22.4 that's an increase of a
little more than 15 percent now is this
an inflection point which in three
months we will look at and Trump will be
down to 30 and DeSantis will be up to 50
Maybe
or is this a short burst for DeSantis
and a short decline for Trump because
DeSantis has been getting way more media
attention lately than Trump has we just
don't know yet if we want to ask a
question that might inform us about
polling it's it's May 31st but we'll
call it the beginning of June what we
might ask is historically how accurate
are primary polls on June 1st of the
year before the election so for example
like in 2016 what was the polling like
June 1st of 2015. we actually have that
data let's put it up on the screen if we
look at 2016
uh in June of 2015 Jeb Bush was leading
by January of 2016 Trump had taken the
lead and Trump ultimately won so in 2016
the leader on June 1st was not
indicative of the eventual winner in
2012 Mitt Romney was leading June of
2011. new Gingrich was leading by
January 1st But Mitt Romney ended up
being the nominee so in 2012 the June
1st polling was indicative of the
eventual winner but it changed if we
look at the Democratic primaries uh the
Democratic primary of 2008 you see that
while Hillary was leading in June of
2007 and in January of 2008 of course
ultimately it was Barack Obama who won
that nomination
and also similarly in 2008 uh in the
Republican primary
a June of the year before Rudy Giuliani
was winning by June 1st Mike Huckabee
had taken the lead but John McCain
ultimately won that primary and we'll
look at a couple others in 2004 June of
2003 it was Joe Lieberman uh January of
2004 Howard Dean had taken the lead of
course the dean's scream we're going to
Iowa
ultimately tanked his campaign John
Kerry the eventual winner of that
primary and then lastly in the year 2000
it was Al Gore in June Al Gore in
January and Al Gore as the eventual
winner so the answer is
often the leader in June of the year
before does not end up being the nominee
that being said usually the leader in
the year before is not a former
president which Donald Trump happens to
be so we are going to follow it but in
the last 10 days or so a significant
gain for DeSantis of about 15 percent
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it and you'll get
15 off when you go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down down below